[Music]
charges about the alleged evils of dark
money otherwise known as anonymous
charitable giving they're rife these
days
senator sheldon whitehouse cites a
multi-hundred million dollar covert
operation to promote conservative
judicial nominations through
donor-advised funds a fast-growing means
of individual charitable giving that
have become a target of progressive ire
the reality is far different in my
latest paper i've reviewed grant data
from the largest donor advice fund
sponsors in the u.s turns out anonymous
giving represents but a small fraction
of their donor's overall giving some
americans do prefer to give anonymously
due to religious or cultural reasons
most don't and public policy related
giving that represents an even smaller
percentage both of anonymous and overall
giving and conservative organizations
they're not even the leading recipients
of anonymous staff money the top 10
anonymously supported grantees in 2020
included the splc planned parenthood and
the aclu memo to senator whitehouse dark
monies not what you think it is
are you concerned about dark money let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei